[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bien je voulais vous dire que je
suis bien content que je suis là ce soir
et que si je serai pas là je serai
certainement
ailleurs je voulais vous dire
que je pure pour vous j'ai les mains Mo
et les pieds
po je voulais vous dire que ce soir j'ai
envie de vous citer cette phrase de
Shakespeare que j'ai écrite moi-même et
qui dit que si qu'on n pas là quand on
est parti on aurait mieux fait de y
aller pour être sûr d'en
[Musique]
revenir
surtout je voulais vous dire que ça fait
20 ans que je suis là et que peut-être
peut-être dans 60 ans dans 70 ans
peut-être plus dans un demi-sècle je
serai toujours là j'aurais alors de
vieill moustache blanche j'aurais une
canne à la main mais j'aime tellement ce
métier que je serai encore là alors
essayez essayez de
m'imaginer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah je suis très très très mux ce soir je
suis toujours
soup de plus en plus dur s de sortir
mimé ne va plus me laisser sortir al
s'il y a quelqu'un qui veut m'aimer ce
soir on me
débarrasse et oui je suis toujours
amoureux parce que l'amour ça ne passe
pas
l'amur c'est comme le feu l'amur il te
ronge et quand le feu est orange il faut
pas
passer chanté une vieille chanson à
propos d'une fille qui a volé mon cœur
et troublé ma
[Musique]
raison vous connaissez son prénom
d'ailleurs
s'appelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Gabriel monprit ton
amour
mon espoir j'end pas je Meur chaque
soir je veux partager autre chose que
l'AV dans ton
lit et entendre la vie plus
mécrire fini fini pour
[Applaudissements]
moi ah je me suis de
oh le roi du
j c'est amusant c'est
amusant je suis trop
vieux plus de mon âge tout ça je suis
trop
vieux beaucoup trop
vieux pourtant il fut un temps où
j'étais l'idole des jeunes moi oui
j'étais l'idole des
jeunes il y a
longtemps tout le soir je veis des
filles qui me courent après j'avais des
fans qui cassaient les fauteuils et puis
maintenant c'est peut-être à moi qu'on
va mettre dans un
fauteeille c'est la vie tu vois plus je
viillis plus je ressemble à un M à qui
on va prendre ses jouets les
projecteurs
quand je rentre chez moi le soir sans
les projecteurs sans les
paillettes sans
vous je m'ennuie je m'ennuie à mourir
peut-être tu vois pour une vieille idole
comme moi c'est encore plus con de
vieillir salut les
gars
[Musique]